the benefits of moringa okay the moringa
plant it's actually a tree and a lot of people
wanted me to do a video on this so i finally
decided to do it it's called the miracle tree
because every part of this tree has very special
properties from the leaves to the flowers to the
seeds to the bark to the sap to the pods the oil
has certain properties that are similar to olive
oil and what's interesting it doesn't go rancid so
apparently it's so loaded with antioxidants it's
protected but here's some of the benefits first
of all it has all of the essential amino acids
number two it has seven times the potassium as
bananas three twice as much protein as milk four
times as much calcium as milk number five seven
times more vitamin c than an orange number six 25
times the iron than spinach now of course it's not
the heme iron but it's still some iron that can
be converted or used by our bodies to a certain
degree number seven it has 36 times more magnesium
than eggs and number eight it has 50 times
more vitamin b3 than peanuts it has 56 times
more vitamin b2 than bananas and number 10 it has
anti-diabetic properties so it's great if you have
blood sugar issues number 11 is anti-arthritic
so it has powerful anti-inflammatory properties
all right number 12 it's a very very powerful
antioxidant and number 13 it's anti acne so
moringa is definitely on the list of superfoods
not only the massive amount of nutrients but also
phytonutrients hey before you go if you're
benefiting from any of my content i would
love to hear about your success story
please share it in the link down below